last year brazil faced the worst forest
fires in a decade
but 2021 could be worse according to
data released
by brazil's national institute for space
research
during the first five months of the year
more than 2
500 square kilometers of amazon
rainforest
have been destroyed it's an area three
times the size of new york city
and half of it was destroyed in may with
charts
showing some of the worst damage since
2015.
compared to the same month last year
deforestation has risen by 67 percent
if nothing changes this year could be
even worse than 2020.
besides the surge in deforestation
brazil is facing a drought
brazil's president jair bolsonaro has
never made the amazon a priority
but after his ally donald trump was
defeated by joe biden through the u.s
presidential elections
he bowed down to international pressure
at april's climate change summit
hosted by biden bolsonaro pledged to
invest more
in environmental enforcement but many in
brazil warned biden
that brazil's government would take no
action to stop wild cat miners
loggers and farmers from destroying the
rainforest
among them 90 year old indigenous tribe
leader hao ni
we got away if this bad president says
something to you
ignore him he wants to allow our forest
to be destroyed by encouraging invasions
on our land
and i don't like it bolsonaro's
government has been accused of weakening
institutions and legislation protecting
the rainforest and the indigenous people
the 2021 federal budget further cut
environmental spending
and brazil's environment minister
jukartasanis
is being investigated for allegedly
obstructing a probe into illegal logging
brazil's vice president emil tomorrow
says bolsonaro will deploy the army once
more to protect the amazon
but environmentalists say the government
must act fast
if it really wants to prevent a disaster
meanwhile land grabbers are losing no
time in may more than 1
300 kilometers of the amazon rainforest
was chopped down
most of the destruction has been caused
by speculators who invade
government-owned land to clear it
they hope to legalize it and sell it at
a good price for cattle and farmers
for land grabbers the chance is now next
year brazil will hold presidential
elections
and bolsonaro may not win a second term
monica yanagiv al jazeera rio de janeiro